Guys, welcome to today's podcast. How are you both feeling? Does somebody have a gun to your head? Yeah. Well, it's just out of frame. It's not so much a gun as a crossbow. I've never seen this. A crossbow.
Welcome to Smartless. Have you ever shot a crossbow? Oh, no. Did I blow it? Welcome to Smartless. Surprise guests, give us a little snapper clap please. There we go. The firecracker. Hi. Hi, how are you guys? How are you? Can I just dive right in? Do you mind?
Oh, you have some prepared material? Go ahead. I don't have prepared material. Guys, I was in the fucking ER again last night. Here's what. Here's what. I had a kidney stone. I thought I was having appendicitis or something. So I had a kidney stone, so I haven't been to bed yet. Wait, how have you not, why did you not cancel this record? No, it's fine. I'm fine, I'm actually in a good mood. Buddy, that would have been such a quick text from me.
How, I hear that's the most painful thing in the world. You can't even know. I haven't had one in years and years. So you had one out or you had one put in? I had one, so the pain was excruciating. I'm like, oh Scotty, I got it, Scotty, I got it. It was awful. Can you tell me where it hurts?
Is it in the tinky or is it in the kidney? No, it's in your side. Yeah, I'm going to say it's in your kidney. Yeah. Hey, oh. And then I'm still a little bit on morphine. I still like have a. Oh, that's kind of fun.
That is kind of fun. Wait a second. So, Shawnee, so you were in the hospital last week or whenever it. That is kind of fun. It is. Wait a second. I've never had. So, Shawnee, so you were in the hospital last week or whenever it was for a couple of times in a night. Like a month ago, yeah. Right, twice in that one night. And then. Yeah, yeah.
And then this. And then you're back and then you get the full scope thing that you went and had done and then you have this. And my question to you is this. Yes, yeah, yeah. Are you paying so much attention to your well-being and your condition that you're, you know what I mean? What do you mean?
No, that was a half a sentence. That because you're so, I'm not saying that experience, is it real? Oh, well, yeah, the fucking kidney stuff. Obviously it's real, but there is a lot of attention paid to your health and to your condition at all times. You're saying, is he potentially creating some of this stuff by having such a close look at it?
Because I'm psychosomatic? I should have prefaced it by saying I'm not a doctor, and I think that you guys know that. But you're on morphine too, so. Yeah, I am. And also not from a doctor. No, but it's like a cycle, I know what you mean, but it's a cycle because if something happens to me,
then I fear that I don't want that thing to happen again. I'm not saying it's psychosomatic, but I am suggesting that maybe you spend so much time and energy thinking about your health and your own condition. I know, I know. That if you were to think about other things or other people, and you do think about other people,
you're a very thoughtful person, but I wonder, do you know what I mean? I don't, again, I don't know. People are gonna think But I wonder, do you know what I mean? Again, I don't know, people are gonna think. But he's being careless with the food that he eats, so that's sort of like keeping his eye off the ball and being sort of lax. That is true, that is true.
It's surprising for somebody who's so concerned with their health, because you are quite on top of it. You should start smoking and you know. Well, yeah, like me. You know what though, I was lying there, I just had like bed head and I have these scabs in my ankles and I had this IV in my arm and I looked at Scottie. I looked at Scottie and I go,
I looked at Scottie and I go, all this could be yours. Can I ask you about where the scabs from the ankles have come from? Yeah, can I ask too? They just- Well, not to see them, just where they came from. I don't know, they just like, I don't know, just just, I don't know, just dry-scanning or whatever. Wait, so now you've just got like old man scabs?
Yeah, he's got old man scabs. I don't know. Sean, I keep, I imagine walking into the gym at Sean's gym, walking into the men's locker room and he's got a hairdryer to his nut sack. He's one of those guys. And you're like, fuck man. Morning. Dude, how you doing? you're like fuck man. Morning.
Dude, how you doing? You're like fucking dude. These fuckers won't drive. What are you? That's funny. By the way Jay, I switched the Nutcracker to the 21st if you want to go. Oh you did? Okay great.
And Willie, please come if you want to. I'm going to be back in New York. And Jay, we're going anyway so if you can go great. If not, we'll do something else. Jay, are you going to be just you, or are you going to bring your Nutcracker with you? No, she'll be there. Okay.
Can you? It's just a great, it's a great blow to the coffee chat, and here comes our guest. Wait a second, I just want to say one more thing. I was just thinking about this, and obviously I smoke from time to time. If you're like, don't smoke. I feel like I'm a world class smoker.
Yeah, you're great at it. You are. I really do. And I feel like- You never smell like cigarettes. You don't smoke a pack a day. Thank you. Thank you very much.
And obviously they're going to play this clip at my, you know, TMZ will play this clip. But it should be noted, it's so great, isn't it? It's a hard thing to beat. Although, you know, when I quit, they didn't have the vapes and the gums and the stickers and shit. So there are things to replace it now.
Yeah. There are things to replace it. You know what, you're gonna, you got a lot of shit and you'll get to it when you want to get to it. No one's pushing you. I know. There are things to replace it, but there's nothing to replace our guest.
Oh, great. You don't even know who our fucking guest is, but you're actually right though. Let morphine molly go. By the way, did you know I was about to say that? No, no. But one of my sort of cheap segues, by the way, I did move today from where I'm doing
the podcast because I wanted to be a little bit cheerier. Oh, okay, good. Oh yeah, yeah, you used to be in the Whisper booth, now you're in your office. Now I'm in my office just because I wanted to. The Jack Shack. I just wanted to be in the, yeah. I wasn't in the Jack Shack.
The Jack Shack, I forgot about my Jack Shack. Remember the Jack Shack. The guru. I think it's, the Jack Shack is, I haven't used it, it's covered in cobwebs. I think they're cobwebs. Okay. But you are right, you are right that our guest today
cannot be replaced and certainly won't be forgotten. I don't know why we even begin to forget because this person is so alive and vibrant right now and has been for a long time. Snaps and clicks were great. You'll like this, they were really good. Those are the kind of snaps and clicks of somebody who has confidence,
the confidence of longevity in doing what they do. And I tell you, somebody who loves longevity is old JB. Yeah, I'm searching for it. And you're going to love this guy because you have a lot, you have certain things in common in that both of you have been performing since you were really, really young on a professional level.
And I love guests like this, and particularly love this guest whom I do not know because they are so fucking talented. Kurt Russell. And funny and cool and smart. It's not Kurt Russell. But this person has been nominated for Shirley MacLean.
And won Emmys, Golden Globes, everything. You can't even imagine the number of films. Sally Struthers. You know him from Igby Goes Down, you know him from Scott Pilgrim Versus the World. Michael Cera. No, it's not Michael Cera. Edgar Wright.
No, you also know him from Soderbergh's No Sudden Move, but you're really gonna know him really, really, really, really, really well from his new film, A Real Pain, but you're really going to know him really, really, really, really, really well from his new film, A Real Pain, but also mostly... Jesse Eisenberg. Succession. Kieran Culkin. It's Kieran Culkin.
Damn, I finally got it. Babin, you ruined the intro when it's just constant guessing. Sally Struthers was close though. Sally Struthers was not a bad guess. That was not. Shirley MacClain was pretty close too. Yeah. Oh, Kieran, I'm so happy to see you there. It's crazy.
This is really exciting for me. This is one of my favorite shows. This has been a long time coming. We had a few times where we were going to have Kieran on and then we couldn't for various reasons that we won't get into. Oh, this is Kieran. I canceled for bullshit like a month ago, and Sean, you didn't even cancel,
you were in the emergency room? Yeah. What, Jay, what were you gonna say? Well, I just wanted to frame up the 90-second delay on Sean there going, oh yes, it's Kieran, just then. No. I know. No.
Fucking morphine is so wrong, right? No, no, because I remember he was supposed to be on, I didn't know who it was, but you must have been that guest that had an issue. Yes, yes. Yeah, mine was not kidney stones. Schedulings. Yeah.
But it was beyond his control. Have you ever had a kidney stone or have you ever seen one? No, to me that's my biggest nightmare, but I thought the, like you said, I thought the pain came from the pee pee, not the dust. No, it starts in your back and the kidney. That's why it's a kidney stone.
And then it works way through to the bladder. And now it's out, so it's sitting in my bladder. So I have another painful thing coming when I pee it out. No, no, no. Because you're going to pee it out. Yeah, because when you pee it out, that's when it hurts. But it only hurts for five, you know, two seconds. Because you're-
They break it down, right? Don't they like break, right? If it's big, this one wasn't big. I think they also have a small tool that can spread your aperture there at the end of your tinky. And that's what's coming through you. Oh, the worst thing I've ever heard.
The meattice, the meattice, the dime slot. It's a clamp. When does that come out? A reverse clamp. It's a dime slot. When does that come out? When is that? Do you just like wait until you're free?
That comes out January 15th, right? Is Presidents Day weekend? Is that what it is? Buy a new mattress, pee out of kidney stone, yeah. Yeah, it's going to be a huge opening weekend. Wait, Shaunie, is that truly the next stage, is the breakdown and then the pee out? Your body breaks it down.
I mean, no, your body doesn't break down. It just passes through, what is that? The thing, the tube that goes from your kidney to your bladder. Eurythra. Penis. No, that's your penis hole. P-tube. Oh God. Something like that.
Anyway, and it hangs out in the bladder. Anyway, Karen, how are you? Such a doctor. This is great. We're doing so well. Anyway, Karen. Welcome to our show. This is, I love this.
This is exactly what I thought it'd be, talking about a bunch of bullshit. I got my wife, or rather Santa Claus got my wife a hoodie last year that said, explain it to me like I'm Tracy. No, come on. Wow. Are you serious? You guys should sue because I didn't buy it through you.
That's merch money that you guys are getting. Is that an Etsy? Is that an Etsy thing? It was like something, I think it was, or like Redbubble or one of those fucking things, you know? Wait, hang on a second, Kieran, I don't wanna interrupt you. Explain it to me like I'm Tracy, I want one of those. I do too.
Hang on, I do wanna say one thing. I can also talk at the same time. No, you can't. I can't believe that JB knows about Etsy. That's the thing that I'm most of those. I do too. Hang on, I do want to say one thing. I can also talk at the same time. No, you can't. I can't believe that JB knows about Etsy. That's the thing that I'm most shocked about. How do you know about Etsy? Dude, where do you think I get my throw pillows? I don't know.
Hang on, I do want to say one thing. I can also talk at the same time. No, you can't. I can't believe that JB knows about Etsy. That's the thing that I'm most of those. I do too. Hang on, I do want to say one thing. I can also talk at the same time. No, you can't. I can't believe that JB knows about Etsy. That's the thing that I'm most shocked about. How do you know about Etsy? Dude, where do you think I get my throw pillows? I don't know.
Karen, my sister is a big fan of yours, by the way. As am I. Wait, Tracy's. That's Tracy. You haven't seen anything of mine, right? Haven't you guys not watched Succession? We're talking about Succession? I'm going to make a sweatshirt that says, find somebody who loves you the way that Tracy loves Kieran.
Why don't we just say that? Get that one. Kieran, I do want to get this out of the way. I am very embarrassed to say I am the only person on the planet that is yet to start, only because I'm very serious about my ingestion of quality product. What, Succession? Yeah, I'm waiting till I can sit down
and just suck it up like the addict that I am. It's one of the biggest shows ever. Everybody I know loves it. I've never heard a bad thing about it. And I'm embarrassed to say I started it and then I was like, okay, I gotta restart it and I have it, but I did see most of season one. You are so fucking funny, dude,
and so facile and so quick. You can so fucking funny, dude, and so facile, and so quick. You can tell that it's, obviously it's really well written and there's a great cast, but you have a facility to you that is really unique and really impressive. Do you know what I mean? I like it. It seems very, I have seen enough clips of not only that,
but everything else you've ever done. I've seen those things. You do seem very comfortable with what you do. You are. And that's like, it's fun to watch. That's lately. Well, well then you were a greater actor than I thought you were,
because you always look like you're having fun, you're not working too hard in the best sense of the phrase. And as a viewer, you're just, you're relaxed watching you do your thing because it looks like you're having fun and you're not stressing about your performance and are you hitting your beats and, you know. Oh God, no, I don't hit beats, yeah,
or marks or any of that stuff. You're rad, you're rad. I can't wait to see real pain. About like 10 years ago, my wife started made fun of me, I was doing a play and I was like I need to go to work and she would work What you do is literally called play Right. No, my wife the same thing doesn't give it up. Yeah. Yeah, but she's like she's kind of right Maybe I'll go out there and just have fun with it and just stick around. This is not extra serious
This is just us, you know, I don't know. I'd like to go out there and play Yeah Do you think that that level of comfort and ease is because you started so young and it was not really ever framed initially to you as like an occupation, a job, a way in which to make a living. Or was it though? Or was it framed as a way of paying the rent?
There's a lot of stuff that I think because I started doing it at six, like that's helped me now is like, I learn lines incredibly fast. You know, I've listened to the show a lot, Jason, and you're the same way. Yeah, that's like Jay. I often, like, on a real pain,
do you guys know Jesse Eisenberg? Oh, not yet. No. Oh, no? I want to. You should meet him. He's just, he's anxiety personified. And nothing caused him more panic than me walking to set and going, what are we shooting today?
And he's like, what? No, there's like a whole page long speech, what's wrong with you? I was like, I learned the lines fast, don't worry about it. And I don't like to rehearse and I just sort of like look it over really quickly and go, oh, those are the words, I'll just, you know. I'll probably fuck up the first take.
Yeah, just go. I'm with you. Yeah. Yeah, JB's really good at that. I think that that could be, obviously it works for you and it's very freeing, right? So that you're not stuck into a- But there are certain parts, if I was more courageous,
I would take on some parts that probably deserve a lot more research, study, practice. But I do really enjoy kind of not acting. I think we've talked about this before, right? I love watching actors that do act and play- We enjoy you not acting. I think we've talked about this before, right? I love watching actors that do act. We enjoy you not acting too. As much as possible. Believe me.
I like being the audience as opposed to being the character. Jason, do you take it personally when everybody keeps encouraging you to direct more? Yeah. Yeah. It's starting to blur. But wait, but Karen, what about on succession,
those big scenes where there's lots of people. Fucking speeches and shit. There's so much dialogue and like, I mean, you almost have to memorize everybody else's lines too, right? Yeah, sort of, and I can do that fast. There was, you know, I've done things like that, like Sarah Snook and I had a really good rapport,
so sometimes I would say, hey, can you just take my lines or vice versa? We even did a scene once by the third take, I just jumped in and stole her line. And gave her a little side eye. And then she looked at me like, all right, game on. And then later on she took mine. That's great. I love that. That's pretty cool. But we ran it like, we started it like a play. There wasn't really a lot of rehearsing. We would go in there, we would always run the full scene,
like three, four, maybe five times. Cameras were always vaguely somewhere. There was no such thing as like coverage, pickup shots. I love that. I remember like in a camera system, he showed up, it was like a new guy, and we were kind of rehearsing. He put a mark down and I just looked,
I stopped the rehearsal and looked at him and said, first day? Yeah. Yeah, that sounds like a rest of development I just stopped the rehearsal and looked at him and said, first day? Yeah. Yeah, that sounds like Arrested Development. You got multiple cameras and they're just sort of tagging different stuff on each take, and by the time you run it three or four times, it's fully covered.
That's why that show was so freaking alive. I'm on my third viewing of that show. That show was great. We were never, yeah, but it's true, we were never really aware of the cameras in that way. And talk about a sense of play, truly, we had that same feeling, which was, it it's true, we were never really aware of the cameras in that way. And talk about a sense of play, truly, we had that same feeling, which was, it was super fun,
and you could kind of do anything. It's so alive that that's why, because you guys were connecting, and you guys were very live, and that's what people respond to, I think. And we also didn't learn our lines before. We would kind of do it, and we'd have a sort of a camera blocking as it were,
it was pretty loose, and we would just kind of, everybody would just kind of throw it out there, and right, JB, how many times, do you remember that time we would come back to shoot the first Netflix season, and the first day, Jason and I had a 12 page two man scene, which was just, do you remember that? And then we were walking towards stage,
Mitch Hurwitz comes up to us and he goes, hey guys, so I kind of rewrote the thing and we're like, uh huh. So he gave us, and we were just going like this, on the way to say going, uh huh, uh huh. And then okay, you're gonna come in here, you come in the front door, all right, I'm gonna go there, you're gonna go there,
and rolling, and here we go. Perfect. And you just kind of fucking go. That was so fun. Yeah, your back's against the wall, you gotta go. And Karen, are you excited to find another project that is similar to that? Is it now a way in which you love to work
that you'd love to replicate on all future jobs? Or do you want something like the polar opposite, where it's very specific and measured? And what do you think? That is a really good question because I think like when I started working on Succession, I had to throw everything that I used to do out the window because I'd never done a TV show before.
My thing was like be off book months before, learn everyone else's lines and be extremely prepared. And then because it's the nature of a TV show where you don't know the next episode and also our show we were getting rewrites on the day, some of what you just said, I had to abandon that and just go fly by the seat of my pants. But it lent itself to that character
because he was the kind of guy who could sort of talk his way in and out of any situation, so he didn't really have to think before he spoke. So it was sort of like he was that guy. So I've been trying to mentally prepare for like, as it feels like going backwards, like, you know, doing a job with coverage and things. And so when we started doing A Real Pain,
I sort of thought we were going to do that, which we did kind of on the first day or so, but the character in that movie is like, the most spontaneous sort of surprising person. It's the kind of thing where just when you think you sort of have him down, just to spite you, he's going to give you a different reaction than what you're expecting.
Which is a great counterbalance to Jesse's character, correct? Exactly, yeah. And he's, you know, and he wrote it, he directed it. He like shot the whole thing. Before I got there, he like shot it on his phone, playing my character, and he would tell me things like, okay, so in this scene you sit over there, and I would go, how do you know?
And he's like, well, what do you mean, how do you know? I was like, well, we haven't tried it. He goes, well, why can't you sit there? I said, maybe I could, but we haven't tried it. What do you mean, why doesn't it work? I'm sure it works. And we talked about it in a frickin' circle for a while. I love you, you get to sit the first day,
he's like, hey, I got a cut of the movie right here. You were great, we're just doing pickups today. So then how was he, you would say, well yeah, maybe I don't sit there, maybe I stand over here. That way he would just throw out all of his coverage and just be like, oh fuck. He kind of abandoned it on the second or third day.
Wow, really? You forced him to? Well, because, yeah, we had to shoot the sequence that he had mapped out, but the whole idea of it was like, I want my picture taken in front of the statue, and then I start gathering the other people in this tour group to come with me. And he had planned it all out. And I was like, well, isn't sort of the point for me to get them into the idea
and we're all going to take a photo together? And he's like, yes, do you mind if we just try it once? And then he basically just told the cinematographer, like never mind, fuck the shot list, pick up the camera. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Dude, that's great though. How cool is that? Then you guys ended up creating something together.
It was much more collaborative. And I wonder if, and JB, you can kind of maybe address this a little bit, having directed so much now. Having that, for Jesse, I don't know, we should ask him. Having that sort of set, that shot list, everything the way he wants to see it, and he was so ready and so regimented, you come in, you kind of throw a wrench in that whole thing,
and I bet you freed him up in a lot of ways. Maybe, I think it freaked him out a lot, though. I'm sure it freaked him out. I think it scared the shit out of him, but yeah. Yeah, because the clock is ticking, you got this call sheet, you got to get done in 12 hours, and it's like, now I got a fucking pain in the ass actor that's throwing it all up in a little blender.
Yeah, but we ended up getting our scenes a lot faster, actually, that's how I felt anyway. I was sort of like, well, you know, let's just run the whole thing a couple of times instead of picking up these little pieces, and then you know, you get to shoot it how you want. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
Kieran, now you're gonna take all of that, that way you're working, all that kind of stuff. How is this going to be different? You're now going to go, and you've worked, obviously, you've done theater before, but you're going back to Broadway. Is that right? In the spring? Yeah, I am. Glengarry Glenross. Glengarry Glenross! God damn it. Can I be in it? Yes, but no. It's already cast. You need an understudy? Who is it with?
It could be my understudy. Bob Odenkirk's in it. Bill Burr, Michael McKean. Okay. Look at that. What a cast. What a fucking cast. I'm terrified.
I thought I was... When do you open? March? I don't know. They don't even have a theater, but they keep telling me that... I think you'll be fine. When do you open? Oh, March? I don't know. They don't even have a theater, but they keep telling me that.
I think you'll be fine. Try the Tabasco. It's spicy, it's big. It's a great theater, the Tabasco. Home of Goodbye Oscar. And it was a great, huge. Good night, good night, good night, Oscar. Good night to you too.
Are you about to ask, Shawna, are you about to ask me about funny theater stories? Yes, yes. Any funny things that happen? If you have any, please share them, I love it. But look, Kieran, you can't be. Let him tell a theater story. Oh, I wasn't actually prompting myself for a funny bit,
I just know that Sean likes to ask that. Or it's audition stories or. Yes, jump in, I love those. Those are my favorite stories, if you have one. I got a really quick one, which is I did a play 10 years ago with Michael Cera. This is our youth, and I had ago with Michael Cera. Nice. This is our youth, and I had food poisoning.
Already funny. The moment the show started and the lights came up, I realized, oh, I'm fucked. So I spent like an hour just trying not to vomit, and by the end of the first act, I had this whole speech, and I realized I can't open my mouth, I'm going to vomit. And I have this whole speech where I have to get the money, there's an amount and what I'm spending it on, and I stood up next to the door to leave the apartment, I'm wobbling,
and I had this speech and there's like a five, six second long pause that's not supposed to be there, and I hold my hand out and I just went, money! And he put the money in my hand, I ran out and the stage manager I guess had put a bucket right next to the door. Oh God. And I started violently, loudly vomiting in this bucket. They were trying to drag me away, but I couldn't. I was just holding onto this bucket for dear life vomiting.
I asked Michael afterwards, I said, could you guys hear me? He goes, are you fucking kidding me? It was the most surreal shared experience I've ever had with a group of people of listening to a grown man vomit in a bucket. Just imagining Michael's just dry takes out to the house while everyone's here just like, it's just, all right. He said he grabbed a comic book
and started trying to casually read a comic book as if this wasn't happening. Until you made your re-entrance? No, the understudy came in in Act Two. No, really? While I spent, yeah, I was vomiting upstairs for the next few hours and they somehow dragged me home for hours more of vomiting.
That's the best theater story we've heard yet, Charlie. That's really good, John. Yes, I think that's really great, I love that. So wait, so this was in London then? No, that one was in New York, but Wikipedia is correct. I did do that play in London like eight years before that. No, no, no, no. Well, you're the one who had time
to actually do the research. I actually do know that you did This Is Our Youth also in London. I have a very close relationship with This Is Our Youth because the original cast, Missy Yeager was in the original cast, who I lived with at the time. She was my girlfriend in the 90s. I knew that. And I remember when they first did it, she and Kenny first did it, and with Mark and Josh Hamilton, I saw it about 42 times.
It's a great play. It's such a brilliant play. I can't let it go. Like I played it as the character Warren in London and I felt like I never got it right. So I spent like years trying to do it again and then realized I actually was right for the other part. I just had to spend years convincing Kenny Lonergan
that I was right for that part. And then I got to do it like in Chicago, Sydney. No way. Wow. I can't seem to let it go. Yeah. Oh, that I did not know. Would it make a good movie? I don't know. I've always tried to crack that one.
I don't think I, I don't know. What about that? What about directing a movie? Directing? Or anything? I don't know. I don't have that thing. You don't have a directing thing? I'm not that ambitious. I doubt that's true.
我不认为我……我不知道。那个怎么样？当电影导演怎么样？当导演？还是别的什么？我不知道。我没有那种天赋。你没有导演的天赋？我没那么大野心。我怀疑这是真的。
I doubt that's true. I don't know. Yeah. You've been around film, you've been making film since you were, as you said, six. Well, first of all, what was the first, let's get into this. What was the first professional experience you had
我怀疑这是真的。我不知道。好吧。你一直在拍电影，正如你所说，你从六岁起就开始拍电影了。好吧，首先，第一部是什——让我们聊聊这个。你从事的第一份专业工作是什么
working in TV, film, et cetera? The first professional experience I had was a commercial when I was six. And I actually don't quite know what it was for, but it was like for something to do with learning disabilities. And I remember that I was put, the concept was I'm standing in front of a chalkboard with chalk in my hand and I don't know how to solve the easy thing in front of me. And the kids in the class are supposed to be calling me dummy and stupid and all that. And I have a distinct memory of being there
在电视、电影等领域工作？我从事的第一份专业工作是六岁时拍的一个广告。其实我不太清楚那是为什​​么拍的，但好像是和学习障碍有关的东西。我记得当时我被安排……那个概念是我手里拿着粉笔站在黑板前，我不知道怎么解决眼前这个简单的问题。班上的孩子们应该叫我笨蛋、傻瓜之类的话。我清楚地记得当时我在那里
and the director going, okay, he's like, action, and he starts going, dummy, idiot, stupid. Oh my God. Wow, the traumatizing. And even then I'm thinking, I get it, I'm six, like stand here and look sad, I'm not fucking method, I'm six, what's wrong with you? Right, right, right.
导演说，好，他说，开始，然后他开始喊，笨蛋，白痴，蠢货。哦天哪。哇，太受创伤了。即便在那时我也在想，我懂的，我才六岁，就像这样站着装可悲就行了，我可不是什么狗屁方法派，我才六岁，你有毛病吧？对，对，对。
Wow. Oh my God. But why do I have, I have this image of you, I can't remember what I was watching where you were either you hosted or your brother hosted SNL and you were. Oh good, I thought you were gonna say I have this image of you on my hard drive.
哇。哦天哪。但为什么我会有……我对你有个印象，我不记得我在看什么了，当时要么是你主持的，要么是你兄弟主持的周六夜现场（SNL），然后你在……哦太好了，我还以为你要说你在我硬盘里有这种照片呢。
Okay, keep going. All right. Well that's, yeah, that too. But wait, why were you on, what was I watching where they did a zoom in on you and you were like on stage on SNL or something. So I hosted SNL a couple years ago and it was 30 years. Oh, that's what it was.
好吧，继续。好吧。嗯，那个，对，那也有。不过等等，为什么你会上……我当时在看什么节目，镜头突然拉近到你身上，你就像是在周六夜现场的舞台上还是什么的。所以几年前我主持过周六夜现场，那是30周年。哦，原来是那个。
It was 30 years almost to the day. It was like a couple days shy of being 30 years from when my brother hosted. And I got to be in like three sketches. So they had like, I got to be there for the good nights and stuff like that. That's really cool. That was so cool.
那是几乎整整30周年。距离我兄弟主持那次差不多只差几天。我得以参演了大约三个短剧。所以他们安排了……我能站在那儿参加道晚安环节之类的。那真的很酷。太酷了。
Was that surreal? That really was. And it was one of those things I thought would never ever happen, but was, there's very few things I, like I said, I'm not very ambitious. I don't have these big aspiring dreams, but hosting SNL was like that one. That one and voicing the Simpsons,
那感觉很不真实吗？确实如此。这是那种我认为绝对不会发生的事情，但……很少有事情我，就像我说的，我没有太大的野心。我没有那些宏伟的抱负，但主持周六夜现场就是其中之一。还有为《辛普森一家》配音，
which I still haven't done yet. Those are the two things I've always wanted to do. Here they come. I remember once, I remember when JB got, was asked to host the first time. This is true story. And you probably don't remember this. And you were first, you got asked to do it.
我到现在还没做到。这是我一直想做的两件事。他们来了。我记得有一次，我记得JB第一次被邀请去主持的时候。这是个真实的故事。你可能不记得了。你是第一个被邀请去做的。
And this was in, you did it in like January of 2005, I think. It wasn't after like the first year or second year of it? Second year, yes. Yeah, it was January 2005. And I remember you going, dude, I'm going to host SNL. I go, that's fucking great. And you go, I mean, it's like a dream come true.
那是在……你大概在2005年1月做的，我想。那不是在第一年或第二年之后吗？第二年，是的。对，那是2005年1月。我记得你说，老兄，我要去主持周六夜现场了。我说，太棒了。然后你说，我的意思是，这就像梦想成真一样。
And I was like, yeah, no shit. It's a fucking, what do you think you're fucking this? This was a dream coming true for me. Oh, is it? No, but a lot of people, but there's a lot of people, and I won't mention their names here, because maybe they're not excited about it, but they will never host SNL,
然后我就想，废话。这他妈的……你觉得你他妈在干嘛？这对我是个梦想成真。哦，是吗？不是，但是很多人，我在这里就不提他们的名字了，因为可能他们对这并不兴奋，但他们永远不会去主持周六夜现场，
because it's so frightening to them. I've heard that, yeah. It's like the thing they would least like to do, and they've turned it down a million times. There's tons of them. Yeah, I guess. I've heard that one. So that's probably where I was coming from.
因为这对他们来说太可怕了。我听说过，是的。这就像他们最不愿意做的事情，他们已经拒绝了一百万次。这样的人多的是。对，我猜吧。我听说过这个。所以这大概就是我的出发点。
Okay, that's a good defense. Do you want to know my favorite good night's stories? Because when you do the good nights at the end, all that's on the cue card is the musical guest and anybody else that showed up. And while you're like five seconds of TV, Lauren goes, okay, enjoy. And I go, what do I say?
好吧，这是个不错的辩解。你想听听我最喜欢的道晚安环节的故事吗？因为当你在最后说晚安时，提词卡上只有音乐嘉宾和任何其他出现的人。当你的电视时间只有五秒钟时，洛恩（Lorne）走来说，好吧，尽情享受吧。我说，我说什么？
He goes, anything you want and walks away. And all I'm doing is looking at the cue cards and then, you know, but I enjoy. And I go, what do I say? He goes, anything you want. And walks away. And all I'm doing is looking at the cue cards. But I said the normal goodnights, but my favorite I've ever seen was Liam Neeson hosted, like in the early 2000s. And the camera cuts to him and he just goes, modest mouse. And then it's just quiet and then they just start playing the music. It's so good. It's just reading the cards, not doing anything. He's literally just read the cue card.
他说，随你想说什么，然后就走开了。我所做的就是看着提词卡，然后，你知道的，但我很享受。我说，我说什么？他说，随便你想说什么。然后走开了。我所做的就是看着提词卡。但我说了正常的晚安词，不过我见过最喜欢的还是连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）在2000年代初主持的时候。镜头切到他身上，他只是说了一句：“羞怯小鼠（Modats Mouse）”。然后就是一片安静，接着他们就开始放音乐了。太棒了。他只是在读卡片，什么也没做。他真的只是在读提词卡。
I love it. It started hugging. But Karen, you can't be you and not be super smart. Like you seem hyper intelligent because while you talk fast, like I usually do, not today on morphine, but you talk, it seems like you're firing on all cylinders. Did they say that you had to smoke the morphine? I don't get it
我太喜欢了。开始拥抱。但是凯伦（Kieran），你不能作为你自己却不是超级聪明。你看起来超级聪明，因为虽然你语速很快，就像我通常做的那样，今天没嗑吗啡，但你说话时，看起来就像全力运转。他们说你得抽吗啡吗？我不明白
So they give you the option like no I have a what is it called a track marks? But but you seem really like you talk fast which means you think fast which means you can probably like to When well was talking to your Jason talking about directing it seems like people who fire in all cylinders all the time can do stuff like that. So if you don't want to do that, what do you do to like... Occupy all that extra bandwidth.
所以他们给你选择，不，我有什么来着，注射痕迹？但是……你看起来真的很像……你语速快，这意味着你思维快，这意味着你可能喜欢……当威尔在跟你、杰森聊到导演时，看起来那些随时全速运转的人就能做那种事。所以如果你不想做那个，你做些什么来……占据所有那些额外的带宽？
Yeah. God, I don't know, drive my wife crazy. I don't even have like hobbies. Crosswords? No, I do like, you know, wordle-quirtle bullshit. Like I know you guys do. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Isn't it weird that I know stuff about you
天哪，我不知道，把我老婆气疯。我甚至没有什么爱好。填字游戏？不，我会玩，你知道的，wordle-quirtle那些扯淡游戏。就像我猜你们也会玩一样。对，对，对。我怎么会知道你的事，不是很奇怪吗？
because I listen to your show too much? Will, pull him in. There's that empty seat. Have you guys do. Oh, yeah, yeah. Isn't it weird that I know stuff about you because I listen to your show too much? Well, pull him in. There's that empty seat. Have you guys ever filled my seat? Yeah, no, we haven't filled your seat. Better way to say that. Yeah. I'm just going to say.
因为我听你们的节目太多了？威尔，把他拉进来。那里有个空座位。你们有没有……哦，对，对。我怎么会知道你的事，不是很奇怪吗？因为我听你们的节目太多了？威尔，把他拉进来。那里有个空座位。你们有谁坐过我的座位吗？对，没有，我们没有坐过你的座位。换个更好的说法。对。我正要说。
We still play every morning. Yeah, I'm still. Quirtle, Quirtle, and Octordle. Do you do the Octordle, too? Octordle I haven't done in a while. A while, yeah. I also like to eat. In a while.
我们每天早上还在玩。对，我还在。Quirtle、Quirtle和Octordle。你也玩Octordle吗？Octordle我已经好久没玩了。好久了，对。我也喜欢吃。好久没玩了。
In a while. What a dipshit. Yeah, you just said I'm smart and I speak fast. Not correctly, but quickly. Quirtle was really, I will say today was really tough and it was a bust. We had three busts on Quirtle today, which was a big, it was sending shockwaves through our turtle,
好久没玩了。真是个笨蛋。对，你刚说我很聪明，语速快。说得不对，但很快。Quirtle真的……我得说今天真的很难，彻底搞砸了。我们今天在Quirtle上惨败了三次，这真是一次沉重的打击，它在我们的turtle、
Quirtle, Wirtle, what we call Nurtle. Now, Karen, I find it hard to believe. Nurtle does exist. It's a math one. You're really saying you do not have a hobby. I don't buy it. Tell me, just tell me what your day is. Well, do you live in New York full-time?
Quirtle、Wirtle，也就是我们叫的Nurtle里掀起了轩然大波。凯伦，我觉得很难相信。Nurtle确实存在。那是个数学游戏。你真的说你没有爱好吗？我才不买账。告诉我，就告诉我你的一天是怎么过的。好吧，你全职住在纽约吗？
Are you a New York guy? I live in New York full-time, but also, I am amazed that people do things in a day. I just don't, I don't get it. So you wake up. Like, I have to find time to, exactly. You get the kid off to school. How many kids do you have?
你是纽约客吗？我全职住在纽约，不过同时，我对人们一天能做那么多事感到惊讶。我只是……我不明白。所以你醒来。就像，我得找时间去，完全正确。你送孩子去学校。你有几个孩子？
Exactly, that's his answer. That's it, that's the whole, I just woke up and then something like I'm already getting ready for bed. How did that happen? What did I do? How many kids do you have? I have two, a three year old and a five year old. So that's my hobby I guess.
没错，这就是他的回答。就是这样，这就是全部，我刚醒来然后就好像已经在准备睡觉了。怎么会这样？我都干了什么？你有几个孩子？我有两个，一个三岁，一个五岁。所以我想这就是我的爱好吧。
Anytime I'm not, like this is really lovely and I really want to be here, but I feel like anytime I'm doing something I'm just trying to get home to be with the kids. Right, exactly. And then are you like me? Do you put on the PJs as soon as you're home, if you know you're not leaving again the rest of the day,
任何时候只要我不在……就像这真的很棒，我也真的很想呆在这儿，但我觉得任何时候只要我在做什么事，我都只想赶快回家和孩子们在一起。对，完全正确。然后你跟我一样吗？一回到家，如果你知道今天剩下的时间再不出门了，你就会换上睡衣吗？
even if it's 1.30 in the afternoon? Yeah. Absolutely. I mean, like, my walking around, like, it's a pair of shorts and a big t-shirt, but yeah, it's the same idea. Yeah. And then, so then, is it television? Is it a book? Like, what are you... You're not just sitting on a couch staring at the wall. God, I haven't read a book since I had a kid, so that would be five years ago. I forgot you're not a reader.
哪怕现在是下午一点半？对。绝对的。我是说，就像，我到处走动时，穿的是短裤和大T恤，但对，是同一个意思。对。然后，所以接下来呢？是看电视？还是看书？比如你在……你总不能只是坐在沙发上盯着墙发呆吧。天哪，自从有了孩子我就没读过书了，那得是五年前了。我都忘了你不是个爱读书的人。
Because the words just keep coming at you, right, Jason? Yeah, TV. Yeah, this is too much. We're watching TV. The words just keep coming at you. They really do, they just, it's relentless. Almost no time for TV or movies, unless I can put it in a schedule, I don't know.
因为文字一直朝你涌来，对吧，杰森？对，电视。对，这有点太多了。我们在看电视。文字一直朝你涌来。真的，它们就是……太无情了。几乎没有时间看电视或电影，除非我能把它排进日程里，否则我不知道。
So when you're done with us today, you log off and then what? I have a little Zoom meeting right after you and then I have to go do some, I'm still doing press for the movie, so then about an hour after that Zoom, I go do press. I actually don't know what the thing is I'm going to. I stopped looking at the itinerary.
所以你今天跟我们聊完后，下线然后做什么？你们之后我有个小Zoom会议，然后我得去做点……我还在为这部电影做宣传，所以在那个Zoom大约一个小时后，我去跑宣传。其实我甚至不知道我要去参加什么活动。我不再看行程表了。
They tell me to get in the car at 11.30, I get in at 12.15 and hope for the best. I literally, this happened a couple weeks ago. I got in the back of a car about 45 minutes late and the guy said Delta Airlines and I went, I don't know. And he said, he goes JFK and I said beats me man. I really don't fucking know. You probably know. And then we literally, I wasn't even sure if I was going to the airport
他们叫我11点30上车，我12点15上去，然后祈求一切顺利。我真的……几周前就发生过这种事。我迟到了大约45分钟坐到车后座上，那家伙说是达美航空（Delta Airlines），我说，我不知道。然后他说，他说是肯尼迪机场（JFK），我说，鬼才知道老兄。我他妈真的不知道。你大概知道。然后我们真的……我甚至不确定我是不是要去机场，
except for that I had a bag that was already packed. I got to the airport, I put my passport in the machine, and as I put it in I realized, I don't know where I'm going today. Wow. Yeah, and it was a good thing too, because it was a long flight. I was going to Warsaw.
除了我有一个已经打包好的包。我到了机场，把护照塞进机器里，就在塞进去的那一刻我才意识到，我今天不知道要去哪儿。哇。对，而且这也是件好事，因为那是一趟长途飞行。我要去华沙。
I'm glad I brought my passport. Why are we going to Warsaw? Warsaw. The movie was shot in... Oh, this movie. Yeah, this movie. It was shot there. How did you like Warsaw?
很高兴我带了护照。我们为什么要去华沙？华沙。这部电影是在……哦，这部电影。对，这部电影。是在那儿拍的。你觉得华沙怎么样？
Yeah, I was about to say. I hardly saw it. We were shooting like six day weeks. More like no saw. Hey, huh? All right, yeah, that was good. Good for you, Will. Thank you.
对，我正要说。我几乎没怎么看到它。我们一周拍六天。应该叫“没怎么看到（No saw）”。嘿，哈？好吧，对，这挺好。做得好，威尔。谢谢。
Poland, I hear, is a very, very beautiful country. Oh, you've been hearing that? I have been hearing that. I have not yet visited yet. Yeah, I'm hearing it a lot. We're like on the grapevine? Yeah, on my text threads. Really nice parks. My wife's from London and she always brags about
我听说波兰是一个非常非常美丽的国家。哦，你一直听到这个？我一直在听到这个。我还没去过呢。对，我经常听到。我们在小道消息里听到的？对，在我的群聊里。非常不错的公园。我老婆是伦敦人，她总是吹嘘
how the parks in London are the best in the world. But the best parks she's ever seen were in Warsaw. Really? Yeah. So she went with you, the kids went with you? At the beginning. They were there for the first like 11 to 12 days and then once they left I was, yeah, popping around.
伦敦的公园是世界上最好的。但她见过的最好的公园在华沙。真的吗？对。所以她跟你一起去了，孩子们也跟你去了？一开始。他们在那里呆了最初大概11到12天，然后他们离开后，我就，是的，到处跑。
And how long were you alone without them? 25 days. That was, yeah. That's a long time. Oh no, that was murderous, yes. 25 shooting days? That's five weeks? 25 full, no, 25 full days.
那你独自一人没有他们呆了多久？25天。那是，对。那是很长一段时间。哦不，那简直是要命，是的。25天拍摄日？那是五个星期？25整天，不，25整天。
25 full days, all right. And actually, yeah, I tried to actually back out of the movie once I saw that that was the schedule. Jesse didn't know about that. Wow. Because I had recently, I don't know if you guys have these rules, like I just did, when I was doing Succession, I had to do eight days away and I was like, that was tough but manageable,
25整天，好吧。其实，是的，我看到那是拍摄日程后，曾试图退出这部电影。杰西都不知道这事。哇。因为我最近……我不知道你们有没有这种规矩，就像我刚做的那样，我在拍《继承之战》时，我必须离开8天，我当时觉得，那很艰难但还能应付，
and then I had to do 11 and went, I can't do that. Eight is my, that's my new rule. Wait, you live in New York, the show is shot in New York. Why would you not do, why? That's not, Jason, that's the opposite of your rule, right? Which is at minimum six months away. Or you're out. Well, they're just so noisy, these kids.
然后我得去11天，我就想，我做不到。8天是我的底线，那是我的新规矩。等等，你住在纽约，这部剧是在纽约拍的。你为什么不……为什么？那不对，杰森，这跟你的规矩正好相反吧？也就是最少离开六个月。否则你就出局。好吧，他们太吵了，这些孩子。
What about, where did you have to go for Succession that took you out for eight and 11 days away from New York? There was a lot of places, you know, like there's usually like once per season watch the show that we ended up somewhere else, you know, Italy, Norway. Sean's never seen us development and we've been doing this podcast and we've been friends for 20 years. I know, still? Yeah, still I haven't.
话说回来，你为了《继承之战》去哪儿了，要离开纽约8天和11天？有很多地方，你知道的，每季通常都会有一次，我们拍这部剧最终去了别的地方，你知道的，意大利，挪威。肖恩从来没看过《发展受阻》，我们一直在做这个播客，而且我们做朋友20年了。我知道，到现在还没看？对，到现在还没看。
Jeez, I've watched it three times. I haven't seen Ozark, it's okay. I always say I've seen it as much as they've watched Will and Grace. I've seen a lot of Will and Grace and I was fucking on Will and Grace. You were on Will and Grace. Yeah, so why don't you fucking, when you're sitting there passing your stone and nothing else, you can't do fuck all, watch a couple episodes. So, you guys shot in incredible locations for Succession.
天哪，我已经看了三遍了。我没看过《黑钱胜地》，没关系。我总是说我看的次数跟他们看《威尔和格蕾丝》的次数一样多。我看了很多《威尔和格蕾丝》，而且我他妈就演过《威尔和格蕾丝》。你演过《威尔和格蕾丝》。对，所以你为什么不他妈的……当你在那里排结石什么也做不了的时候，你他妈什么都干不了，看几集呗。所以，你们为《继承之战》在令人难以置信的地点拍摄。
That I do know. You guys shot like in... Croatia, Tuscany, Norway. We were all over the map. I know, how good is that? But it wasn't that nice. I remember at the end of season two, my wife was heavily pregnant.
这点我确实知道。你们在……克罗地亚、托斯卡纳、挪威拍摄。我们到处跑。我知道，那有多棒？但其实没那么好。我记得第二季结束时，我老婆怀着身孕。
It was August, she's back in New York and she was basically complaining about how hot it was and she was alone and all that stuff. And she's like, and you're on a yacht in Croatia. I'm like, I'm not on a yacht, I'm on a fucking set. It's not like I'm going swimming between takes and all that. It's like, that's the thing when we travel in all these places, unless you can specifically
那是八月，她回到了纽约，她基本上在抱怨天气有多热，她一个人在家诸如此类的事。然后她说：“而你在克罗地亚的游艇上。”我说：“我不在游艇上，我他妈在片场。又不是说我在两个镜头之间还能去游泳什么的。”这就是我们去所有这些地方旅行的情况，除非你能专门
get some time off after, you're not really seeing the stuff. Yeah. I don't know. Wait, wait, Kieran, so you've always been a New Yorker, I wanna get back to this, because I saw a video, something of you recently, not even in anticipation of doing this, I just saw it out in the world of you
在之后空出一些时间，否则你根本看不到那些东西。我不知道。等等，等等，凯伦，所以你一直是个纽约客，我想回到这个话题，因为我最近看到一个关于你的视频，甚至不是为了做这个节目才看的，我只是在外界看到了你
revisiting your childhood apartment. Oh wow, yeah. Oh yeah, that was on CBS Sunday Morning, which is a great show, right? That was a great show. Yeah, and it was really cool, and I loved you going in and then seeing your former neighbor. That was not planned at all.
重访你的童年公寓。哦哇，对。哦对，那是在CBS周日早间新闻（CBS Sunday Morning）上，那是个很棒的节目，对吧？那是个很棒的节目。对，真的很酷，我喜欢你走进去然后看到你以前的邻居。那根本不是计划好的。
We were just like, they were setting up a camera outside and he was like, oh, hi, Kieran. I looked up and I was like, Alice? Oh, thanks. Yeah, it really worked. Talk a little bit about growing up in New York and auditioning for stuff and what that was like. And now, as I mentioned in the lead in,
我们当时只是……他们在外面架设摄像机，然后他就说，哦，嗨，凯伦。我抬头一看，就说，爱丽丝？哦，谢谢。对，效果真的很好。聊聊在纽约长大、去试镜以及那是什么样的经历吧。现在，正如我在引言中提到的，
Jason, we often talk about people, about being able to have that longevity and be able to kind of take what you, be a child actor and have that translate into becoming an adult actor as well is really rare. Yeah, petrified. I feel like, other than what I mentioned earlier about like learning lines fast and knowing that stuff, I feel like, other than what I mentioned earlier about like learning lines fast
杰森，我们经常谈论人们能够拥有那种长寿的职业生涯，能够把你的……作为一个童星的经历转化为成年后也能成为演员，这真的很少见。对，吓死我了。我觉得，除了我刚才提到的像快速背台词并了解那些东西之外，我觉得，除了我刚才提到的像快速背台词
and knowing that stuff, I feel like everything I did as a kid, I don't think I apply any of the acting stuff I used to do as a kid to what I do now. Really? Yeah, because sometimes I see that in former kid actors, I don't know if you know what I'm talking about, where there's sort of like bad habits you can sort of pick up along the way that you just have to be mindful to. Right, you mentioned, in Igby, the director was like,
并了解那些东西之外，我觉得我小时候做的所有事情，我用的那些演戏的东西，我一点也没有应用到我现在做的事情中。真的吗？对，因为有时我在其他前童星身上看到过那种情况，我不知道你们知不知道我在说什么，就是你一路上可能会养成一些坏习惯，你必须时刻注意。对，你提到过，在《伊基·比》里，导演说，
I'm seeing the kid tricks, just fucking knock it off and be better, basically. Yeah, stop showing me what you're doing, you know? Stop, you know, yeah, stop trying to show me what the character's doing, stop showing me what's happening in the scene. Like, you know, that's my job. Yeah, force us to lean in and read your mind, right?
我看到你的童星把戏了，快他妈收起来，表现得更好点，基本上就是这样。对，别再向我展示你在做什么了，你知道吗？别再，你知道的，对，别再试图向我展示角色在做什么，别再向我展示现场发生了什么。就像，那是我的工作。对，强迫我们去倾听并读懂你的心思，对吧？
So you kind of, you shifted what you did, like Jason, I'm sure a lot of stuff that you used to do, like on Growing Pains, is now different, right? No, no, no, that's Kirk Cameron, Will. I'm sorry. Can I talk to you for a second? Yes. Kirk Cameron.
所以你某种程度上改变了你的做法，就像杰森，我确信你以前做的很多事情，比如在《成长的烦恼》里的，现在都不同了，对吧？不，不，不，那是柯克·卡梅伦（Kirk Cameron），威尔。抱歉。我能跟你说句话吗？可以。柯克·卡梅伦。
This whole time? The whole time, I've never been, yeah. But now, Karen, did you have the same level of panic and horror when you were start thinking about my God, am I gonna be able to transition my ability to make a dollar into adulthood or should I go to college? Should I get something where I have a diploma
这一整场？一直以来，我从来没有……对。但现在，凯伦，当你开始思考“天哪，我还能把赚钱的能力延续到成年吗，还是我该去上大学？我该去拿个文凭，
and I have a reasonable expectation of sort of a base salary and some consistency and predictability in my life? God, I don't really think all that often. So all I know is, like, I suddenly found myself at like 20 and I remember my manager, who I'm still with, I've been with her for 30 years, she like used the word career and I kind of panicked because I've been doing it since six.
对底薪以及生活中的某种稳定性和可预测性有一个合理的期望”时，你也有过同等级别的恐慌和恐惧吗？天哪，我其实没经常想那么多。我只知道，我突然发现自己到了20岁左右，我记得我的经纪人——我到现在还跟她合作，我已经跟她合作30年了——她用了“职业生涯”这个词，我当时有点恐慌，因为我从六岁起就在干这个了。
But it's like, a six year old shouldn't really pick their occupation for the rest of their life. That's not really, they're not really qualified to do that. You know? So I think I kind of panicked and was like, okay, well I don't know if this is what I want to do. So I think I spent many years trying to figure out what I want to do and doing this in the meantime.
但这就好像，一个六岁小孩其实不应该为余生选择职业。那真的……他们实在不具备做这种决定的资格。你知道吗？所以我猜我当时恐慌了，心想，好吧，我不知道这到底是不是我想做的事。所以我想我花了很多年试图弄清楚我想做什么，而与此同时一直在做这个。
Yeah. At that point you're 20, so you could still kind of start college, you'd be a 20 year old freshman, which is not cute, but you still could have done it. I'm a high school dropout as well. I don't really, you know, yeah. Yeah.
对。那时候你20岁，所以你其实还是可以开始上大学，你会是一个20岁的大一新生，虽然不太可爱，但你本来还是可以做到的。我也是个高中辍学生。我其实不怎么……你知道的，对。对。
But like Jason, you asked, remember we asked this recently to Carrie Russell, and she was like, no, I had no thought about making the leap from being a child actor to, like she didn't worry about it at all. You did, you were cognizant of it. I did, but I still didn't do anything to mitigate the risk. In other words, I wasn't taking like night classes
但就像杰森，你问过——还记得我们最近问过凯丽·拉塞尔（Keri Russell）吗？她说，不，我从来没想过要跨越从童星到……就像她根本不担心这个。你有，你当时是有这种认知的。我有，但我还是什么都没做来降低风险。换句话说，我没有去上什么夜校
in real estate, you know? Like it was just, I mean, it's really fucking stupid what I did and what you did, Karen, what Carrie did. Like we're still at this, I mean, it's really fucking stupid what I did and what you did, Karen, what Cary did. We're still at this, I'm 55, I'm still running sort of wild, great show, by the way. That was me and Cary Russell. Like if this doesn't work out in the next, what,
学房地产，你知道吗？我的意思是，我做的事真的很他妈蠢，你也是，凯伦，凯丽也是。我们还在干这个，我的意思是，我做的事真的很他妈蠢，你也是，凯伦，凯丽也是。我们还在干这个，我55岁了，我还在像脱缰野马一样乱跑，顺便说一句，这节目真棒。那是我和凯丽·拉塞尔。如果接下来……什么，
six months, things could go completely dry. At any point in any of our careers, and we don't have a diploma or a degree in something that says, no, no, no, I'm knocking on the door. I should, give me a job. But isn't that the thing that drives you? Is that fear? Yeah, but you know, this anxiety that's behind all the time.
六个月内事情没有好转，一切可能彻底完蛋。在我们职业生涯的任何阶段，我们都没有文凭或学位来证明“不，不，不，我在敲门了，你应该给我一份工作”。但难道不是这种恐惧在驱使着你吗？对，但你知道的，这种焦虑一直潜藏在背后。
I know. I think a really good antidote to that also, for me, has been rich parents. Yeah, you fucker. I'm kidding, I'm kidding, they're not. That must be really nice, yeah. I'm kidding, I'm kidding, they're not. That must be really nice, yeah. I'm being flippant, it's not true, it's not true.
我知道。对消解这个很有用的一点，对我和来说，也是有富有父母。对，你他妈的。我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的，他们没有。那一定很棒，对吧？我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的，他们没有。那一定很棒，对吧？我只是随口说说，不是真的，不是真的。
I remember my grandma, like about 20 years ago, she was in North Dakota, she asked me like, she goes, you still acting? I said, yeah. And she goes, when was your last job? And I said, oh God, like a little over a year ago. And she goes, you should get into meat. People always need meat.
我记得我奶奶，大概20岁的时候，她在北达科他州，她问我，她说：“你还在演戏吗？”我说：“对。”然后她说：“你上一次工作是什么时候？”我说：“哦天哪，大概一年多前吧。”然后她说：“你应该去卖肉。人们总是需要肉的。”
Huh. Really? Really, your grandma said that? Not terrible. Not terrible. Not terrible advice. Yeah, people will always eat it. Yeah. We'll be right back.
哈。真的吗？真的，你奶奶这么说的？不算太差。不算太差。不算太差的建议。对，人们总是要吃肉的。对。我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show. Forgive me, is it just you and Macaulay that were actors, or were there other people in your family? My brother, Roy, actually at some point, we were all sort of like given the opportunity to act, and some of them just didn't take to it, some did. And then? Of all seven of us.
现在，回到节目中。原谅我，只有你和麦考利（Macaulay）是演员，还是你们家里还有其他人？我弟弟罗伊，其实在某个时候，我们都得到了演戏的机会，有些人就是不喜欢，有些人喜欢。然后呢？我们七个全都是。
And then parents and- Seven kids. Seven kids, yeah. In that small little apartment. Sorry, where do you fall in that? Right in the middle, yeah. But I don't really have that middle child thing. Because I was like the favorite.
然后父母和——七个孩子。七个孩子，对。在那个小小的公寓里。抱歉，你在其中排行老几？正好中间，对。但我其实没有什么中间孩子的特权感。因为我是最受宠的。
Yep, there you go. I don't really believe in birth order as much as other people do. You're one of four, right, Willie? Yeah. I was the baby for almost 10 years then my brother was born. So, you have two older sisters.
对，就是这样。我对出生顺序的信仰没有其他人那么深。你是四兄弟姐妹中的一个吧，威尔？对。我有将近十年是老幺，然后我弟弟出生了。所以，你有两个姐姐。
And I don't know, I just don't buy into it. Yeah, you make of it what you will, like any way. Yeah, exactly. Whatever you want to. We're all capable of anything. Will, real quick, their names? Halem, Jack Watt, and Jack Watt.
而且我不知道，我就是不买账。对，随你怎么想，反正都行。对，exactly。随你便。我们所有人都有无限可能。威尔，快说，他们的名字？海伦（Halem）、杰克·瓦特（Jack Watt）和杰克·瓦特。
We'll let you come back on that. Okay, I do love them, I think. Look at them. Shawn, you have a question for our guest? No, I was just saying, but then as far as the lineage of the Kulkan family. The loving of Sean just threw up right now. And the kidney stone comes out my throat instead of my penis. Guys, I passed it.
我们待会儿再让你回答这个。好吧，我确实爱他们，我想。看看他们。肖恩，你有什么问题要问我们的嘉宾吗？不，我只是想说，但是就卡尔金（Culkin）家族的血统而言。爱肖恩的人刚才直接吐了。肾结石从我喉咙里冒出来而不是从我阴茎里。伙计们，我排出去了。
No, but parents and grandparents and like, or did this acting bug start with you, the kids of the cult? I think my father and his siblings did it as kids. That's sort of my understanding. Because actually I only know that because a few years ago we went through an old storage unit and I found this like pamphlet of I guess what his parents were trying to like, I don't know exactly what it was, but it was like, hey, we have a son that's an actor, and we have this other son that's a magician. And it was like sort of like,
不，但是父母和祖父母，或者说这个演戏的基因是从你们卡尔金家的孩子开始的吗？我想我父亲和他的兄弟姐妹小时候就演过。我是这么理解的。因为其实我之所以知道这个，是因为几年前我们清理一个旧储藏室时，我发现了这个小册子，我想那是他父母试图……我不知道具体是什么，但就像是，嘿，我们有个儿子是个演员，我们还有个儿子是个魔术师。这就好像是，
we have these performing arts kids. Wow. Isn't it amazing the stuff you find out about your parents way later? Like, I grew up without knowing anything about my mom, or obviously my dad, but my mom. No idea your dad was such a great driver. I know.
我们有这些表演艺术的孩子。哇。你很久以后才发现关于你父母的事，是不是很神奇？比如，我对妈妈一无所知地长大，当然还有我爸爸，但关于我妈妈。完全不知道你爸爸车开得那么好。我知道。
Do you know the make of the car? At least? You didn't know that your dad didn't own a map, I guess? He had a bad memory, or he had a bad memory. Wait, do you guys remember that car, the MG? The MG, the one-star? My dad owned that. No kidding.
你知道那是什么牌子的车吗？至少？你不知道你爸连个地图都没有吗？他记性不好，或者他记性不好。等等，你们还记得那辆车吗，MG？那辆MG，那辆单座车？我爸有一辆。不是吧。
He built a car built for one. Built for barely two five kids that's the first sign you should have punct. Like, that's such a red flag. Oh, God. That's such a red flag. The joke never gets old. You know what the other red flag was? When he said, I'm fucking out of here. Oh, man. So fucking funny. This is so weird for me because it feels like, like, you're just meeting me, but I feel like
他造了一辆只够一个人坐的车。勉强坐得下两个大人五个小孩，那是你应该及时止损的第一个信号。真是一个巨大的红旗。哦，天哪。真是个巨大的红旗。这个笑话永远不会过时。你知道另一个红旗是什么吗？当他说，我他妈要离开这儿的时候。哦，天哪。太他妈搞笑了。这对我来说太诡异了，因为感觉就像……就像你们才刚认识我，但我感觉
I'm hanging out with my old friends and just talking with each other. You are. We are. My wife used to tell me for months, she was listening to me, but I feel like I'm hanging out with my old friends that are just fucking with each other. You are. My wife used to tell me for months, she was listening to the show before I listened to it, this happened on more than one occasion, she'd be like, oh my friend said blah blah blah the other day, we were having this chat, and I said, which friend was it?
我是在跟老朋友闲逛，大家互相开玩笑。你确实是。我们是的。我老婆几个月来一直告诉我，她一直在听，但我感觉我是在和我的老朋友们闲逛，大家只是互相瞎胡闹。你确实是。我老婆几个月来一直告诉我说，在我听之前她就在听这个节目，这种情况发生过不止一次，她会说：“哦，我朋友那天说巴拉巴拉，我们当时在聊这个。”我说：“那是哪个朋友？”
And she'd think, oh fuck, that was smartless. It happened all the time. Who was that, was that Sean, was that Will? No, I know, she actually, like a couple months ago we were at this, because her favorite episode is the one you guys did with Matthew Reese. Oh yeah. She loved it. She listened to it more than once.
然后她会想：“哦操，那是SmartLess。”这种事经常发生。那是谁，是肖恩，还是威尔？不，我知道，她其实……几个月前我们在参加这个……因为她最喜欢的一集是你们和马修·里斯（Matthew Rhys）录的那期。哦对。她超爱。她听了不止一遍。
So we're at this party and she goes, Oh, Matthew's here. Let's go say hi. And she started dragging me over. And I was like, Matthew who? And then right before we got to him, she stopped me and started pushing me away. She goes, Never mind. We haven't met him. We're not friends. Oh my god, that's smart. I love her already. What is her name?
所以我们在一个派对上，她说：“哦，马修在这儿。我们去打个招呼吧。”然后她开始把我拽过去。我说：“马修谁？”然后就在我们走到他跟前之前，她突然停下来把我推开了。她说：“算了。我们不认识他。我们不是朋友。”哦天哪，太精明了。我爱死她了。她叫什么名字？
Jazz It's not short for anything actually right when I met her I was one of the first things I said it's not it's dumb I when I first met her I shook her hand and I said, uh, so what's your name? She wouldn't jazz I said jazzy like the music she went. Yeah, I said, well, that's fucking stupid It just came out of me, and I went right away, I was like, I blew it, but instead she laughed, so it worked out all right. Where were you when you guys met?
爵士（Jazz）。其实不是任何名字的缩写，对，我刚遇到她时，那是对她说的第一句话之一。那太蠢了。我刚遇到她时，我跟她握手，我说：“呃，你叫什么名字？”她说：“爵士。”我说：“像爵士乐那样吗？”她说：“对。”我说：“嗯，那真他妈蠢。”这话脱口而出，我当时马上就想，我搞砸了。但相反她笑了，所以结果还不错。你们俩在哪儿遇见的？
Tell us the story, is it a meet-cute? At a bar, but that was it. I mean, what I love about the story is it's fast. That was pretty much it. The only other thing was, when I walked into a bar, I was with a friend. Is that your ride? I saw her. Yeah, that's a, this is New York City.
给我们讲讲这个故事，这是一见钟情吗？在一个酒吧里，但也就那样。我的意思是，我喜欢这个故事的一点在于它进展很快。差不多就是这样。唯一的其他事情是，当我走进酒吧时，我和一个朋友在一起。那是你的车吗？我看到她了。对，这个是……这是纽约市。
Yeah, this is third. You're like, I don't know where the car's taking me. It's my dealer. It's my dealer. I walked in a bar, I saw her and I yelled, holy shit. Yeah. And I basically said, New York. New York.
对，这是第三大道。你会说，我不知道车要带我去哪儿。我的毒贩。我的毒贩。我走进一家酒吧，我看到她，我大喊：“卧槽。”对。我基本上说的是……纽约。纽约。
And I was with this dude and I said like, hey, we need to go stand near this girl, which I realize now sounds kind of creepy. Yeah, very. And so we stood near her. That's what we had to do before these dating apps. which I realize now sounds kind of creepy. And so we stood near her. So what we had to do before these dating apps, you just had to kind of circle. Yeah, you show up.
我当时和这家伙在一起，我说：“嘿，我们得去那个女孩附近站着。”我意识到现在听起来有点 creepy（毛骨悚然）。对，非常。所以我们就站在她附近。这就是我们在这些约会软件出现之前必须做的……我意识到现在听起来有点 creepy。所以我们就站在她附近。这就是我们在这些约会软件出现之前必须做的，你只能到处晃悠。对，你露面就行。
It's fucking easy now, right? This was 13 years ago. She was sitting at a table with some dude and the moment he got up to leave to go to the bathroom, I just jumped in there and stole his seat. No way. And I literally, all I did is I sat down and said, sorry, I just stole your friend's seat.
现在他妈的太容易了，对吧？那是13年前的事了。她和一个男的坐在一张桌子旁，那男的一站起来离开去洗手间，我就直接冲过去占了他的座位。不会吧。我 literally（简直），我所做的就是坐下来说：“不好意思，我刚刚偷了你朋友的座位。”
And she went, that's okay. I said, was that your boyfriend? She said, no. I said, do you have a boyfriend? She went, no. I said, then all I did is I sat down and said, sorry, I just stole your friend's seat. And she went, that's okay. I said, was that your boyfriend? She said, no. I said, do you have a boyfriend? She went, no. I said, then I'm Kieran. Wow. Oh wow.
然后她说：“没关系。”我说：“那是你男朋友吗？”她说：“不是。”我说：“你有男朋友吗？”她说：“没有。”我所做的就是坐下来说：“不好意思，我刚刚偷了你朋友的座位。”然后她说：“没关系。”我说：“那是你男朋友吗？”她说：“不是。”我说：“你有男朋友吗？”她说：“没有。”我说：“那我是凯伦。”哇。哦哇。
I've never been that forward in my life. And then she said, I'm Jazz. And you said, that's fucking stupid. And I said, that's fucking stupid. And then what are you drinking? You guys have been making music ever since. Where, what, what, what, what, what, what putter tower you in?
我这辈子都没这么主动过。然后她说：“我是爵士。”然后你说：“那真他妈蠢。”我说：“那真他妈蠢。”然后呢，你们在喝什么？你们从那以后一直在做音乐。你们在……你们在哪个塔楼里？
Do you remember? It was, what the hell was the name of the place? It was on 7th and A, it was called Cabin Down Below. Oh nice. Do you know that one? I don't know if I know Cabin Down Below. 7th and A, so that is Lower East Side? I want to start in there.
你记得吗？那是……那地方叫什么名字来着？在第七街和A大道交口，叫Cabin Down Below。哦，不错。你知道那个地方吗？我不知道我知不知道Cabin Down Below。第七街和A大道，所以那是下东区？我想从那儿开始。
Lower East Side, it was one of those places where I kept getting like turned away, because they kept, every time I tried to go there, they were like, it's a private party, because I wasn't dressed cool or I wasn't famous. But they knew my wife. There was one time I went there and I was with a couple of, I'm not meaning to name drop, I was there with a couple
下东区，那是那种我一直被拒之门外的酒吧，因为他们……每次我想去那儿，他们都说：“这是私人派对”，因为我穿得不够酷，也不出名。但他们认识我老婆。有一次我去那儿，我和几个……我不是故意要炫耀人脉，我和几个
of like, famous-y people. And I walked up first and they were like, sorry, private party. And I looked back at one of my friends, I'll just tell you who it was, it was Scarlett Johansson, she's like, I got this. And she walked up, she goes, hi, they're with me, and he looked at her and said, it's a private party. And then he looked up, he looked up and went, jazz?
比较出名的人一起去的。我第一个走上前，他们就说：“抱歉，私人派对。”我回头看了一眼我的朋友——我直接告诉你们是谁吧，那是斯嘉丽·约翰逊（Scarlett Johansson），她说：“我来搞定。”她走上前说：“嗨，他们跟我一起的。”那家伙看着她，说：“这是私人派对。”然后他抬起头，抬起头说：“爵士？”
And she was like, yeah, I was like, oh, are they with you? And she went, yeah, come on in. Jazz for the win. One of those fucking people, she's like, that's one of those New York fucking jazz. Jazzy jazz. She's just one of those people, man. She makes friends everywhere.
她就说：“对。”我说：“哦，他们跟你们一起吗？”她说：“对，请进。”爵士赢了。她就是那种人，她就像……那是那种纽约的爵士。爵士风的爵士。她就是那种人，伙计。她到哪儿都能交到朋友。
Now, since you guys are, since acting is generational, what about the three-year-old and the five-year-old? What are you thinking? I'm not against that. You're gonna support it? Yeah, I mean, I had a really nice experience with it growing up. Me too.
既然你们……既然演戏是代代相传的，那三岁和五岁的两个孩子呢？你们是怎么想的？我不反对这个。你会支持吗？对，我的意思是，我小时候有过非常美好的经历。我也是。
Yeah, it was nice. However, it is that thing, getting back to that other point, is like, are you going to, at some point, I would imagine you would say, now, would you want to kind of help your odds a little bit by going to college at the same time, maybe? I would probably encourage an education. I never got one. But, I don't know. I would probably encourage that. But, I don't really know.
对，挺好的。不过，回到刚才那个问题，就是，你……在某个时候，我猜你会想，你是不是会想同时去上大学，稍微帮自己增加一点胜算？我可能会鼓励他们接受教育。我当年没接受过。但是，我不知道。我可能会鼓励那个。不过，我其实也不知道。
I've also heard of people, this is something I kind of wish, it hasn't come to bite me in the ass really, but I remember doing a lot of press as a kid, and I feel like I would maybe try to protect them from doing that a bit. Because sometimes I'll get quoted on something stupid, I said, I'm like, I was 13, that's not what I actually think. Like I don't, you know.
我也听说过有人——这也是我有点希望的，虽然没真正咬我一口——我记得小时候做过很多宣传采访，我觉得我可能会试着保护他们免受那些采访的影响。因为有时候我会被引述说一些愚蠢的话，我说过的话，然后我想，我当时才13岁，那根本不是我真正的想法。就像我……你知道的。
What about? Shawn, remember that time you paid that guy to bite you in the ass? Sorry, it just reminded me of that story. Surprisingly cheap too, wasn't it? Yeah, I mean he lowered his rates for me. That's really funny. There's also the part about like training yourself
关于什么？肖恩，还记得你花钱让那个家伙咬你屁股的事吗？抱歉，我突然想起那个故事了。出奇地便宜，对吧？对，我的意思是，他为我降价了。太好笑了。还有一部分是关于训练你自己
to believably be someone else at a time when you're trying to figure out who you are. Like starting to act when you're a little kid, did that ever screw you up at all? No, I think other things probably screwed me up. I don't know if that was it. What fucked you guys up? You feeling pretty balanced now? Self analysis or professional analysis?
在试图弄清楚自己是谁的时候，去令人信服地扮演另一个人。像小时候就开始演戏，那有没有把你的脑子搞砸过？没有，我觉得其他事情可能把我的脑子搞砸了。我不知道是不是那个。什么把你们的脑子搞砸了？你们现在觉得挺平衡的吗？自我分析还是专业分析？
I'm a big fan. Therapy, therapy, therapy? No therapy, I prefer to go undiagnosed. I love therapy. Yeah, me too. I should, I know if you guys, ugh. Long walks work too. Yeah.
我是它的超级粉丝。治疗，治疗，治疗？不要治疗，我宁愿保持未确诊状态。我喜欢治疗。对，我也是。我应该……我不知道你们，呃。长途散步也管用。对。
Sean, you go to therapy? I go to therapy every week. Oh yeah, you do. Instead of dumping it all on Scotty, I just pay somebody to listen. Again, you pay somebody to dump it all on you. Damn it, you do. It's I instead of dumping it all on Scotty. I just pay somebody to listen again Alright Kara, what about are we a Sports fan television show fan you said no
肖恩，你去接受心理治疗吗？我每周都去。哦对，你确实去。与其把所有情绪都倾倒在斯科蒂（Scotty）身上，我宁愿花钱找个人听我说。再说一次，你是花钱找个人让别人把情绪倾倒在你身上。该死，你确实是。我……与其把所有情绪都倾倒在斯科蒂身上。我只是花钱找个人听我说。好吧，凯伦，关于……我们是体育迷还是电视节目迷？你刚才说不
No, I don't do anything. It's so like it's yeah, I don't understand hobbies. I don't do anything. Ciro. I don't understand it. I don't know. I just don't have time. I don't even get to the gym. So do you meet people for coffee? Do you like what you do? No, I don't really even have friends anymore. What will you click and you just hang up?
不，我什么都不做。这就好像……对，我不理解爱好。我什么都不做。塞罗（Ciro）。我不明白。我不知道。我根本没时间。我甚至没时间去健身房。那你会约人喝咖啡吗？你喜欢你做的事吗？不，我甚至真的没有朋友了。什么，你要点击然后直接挂断吗？
Kind of. What will you do after this, Karen, after you're done with this little... He's got to zoom and then he's got to go do more press. I got like a press thing and I got the thing. I like doing this. This is kind of a new one. I think I need therapy because I like doing, I like flower arrangements now. Do you really?
差不多吧。凯伦，你做完这个之后要做什么，做完这个小……他有个Zoom会议，然后还得去做更多宣传。我有个宣传活动，还有个别的活动。我喜欢做这个。这算是一个新的。我觉得我需要治疗，因为我喜欢做这个，我现在喜欢插花。真的吗？
There you go. I like doing that. That gives me some calm. What about a garden on the roof of your apartment? That's such a nightmare. It's New York. That's not going to be nice. There's public gardens.
你看。我喜欢做那个。那能给我带来一些平静。在你公寓屋顶上搞个花园怎么样？那简直是一场噩梦。这是纽约。那可不会好。有公共花园。
You can rent a public garden in a public... Bit of a bummer too, I find. I'll do crafts with you till we fucking... Careful, Karen. All the time. Until what? Yeah, I don't know. But we could get macaroni and glue
你可以在公共场所租一个公共……这其实挺扫兴的，我觉得。我可以陪你做手工艺品，直到我们他妈的……小心，凯伦。一直这样。直到什么？对，我不知道。但我们可以买通心粉和胶水
and make stuff on a paper plate. I can do that with my children, but yeah, please come on over. Yeah. Don't have them over the house. You can join us, we got all that stuff. He's turned into a morphinetic, he's going to steal your silverware.
然后在纸盘子上做手工。我可以和我的孩子们一起做，不过对，请过来吧。对。别在他们家办。你可以加入我们，我们有所有这些东西。他变成了一个吗啡迷，他会偷你的银器的。
It's not. I'll never leave him alone with the kids, but yeah, he can come over, he's supervised. Now when do you start rehearsals on the play? Oh gosh, February or something like that. That terrifies me because... Can we get a commitment? Can the three of us come to the opening night of your play?
才没有。我绝不会把他一个人留给孩子们，但对，他可以过来，他在监督之下。那你什么时候开始为那部戏剧排练？哦天哪，二月份左右吧。这让我感到害怕，因为……我们能得到一个承诺吗？我们三个人能去看你戏剧的首演吗？
Yeah, you're invited. The public is inviting you, my stupid ass. No, I'm asking... You need me to give up one of my five tickets to you three? Yes. I mean I could, yeah fine, fuck it. Yeah, except leave them alone though. I'm sure you have connections yourself,
对，你们被邀请了。公众在邀请你们，我这蠢货。不，我是说……你需要我把我的五张票分一张给你们三个吗？对。我是说我可以，好吧，操，去他的。对，除了别管他们。我确信你自己也有人脉，
but fine, you three are my guests. We want to come. No plus ones though. Exactly. Now is Jazz in the business as well? No, not at all. But she understands enough about what you do to... It's taken a while.
不过好吧，你们三个是我的贵宾。我们想来。不过没有带随行人员的。完全正确。现在爵士（Jazz）也在这一行吗？不，完全不在。但她对你的工作了解得足够……这花了一段时间。
She used to think that, she goes, I don't understand why actors get awards and things. She's literally thought that directors puppeteered the actor, told him where to sit and the cadence on how to speak. So that's literally what her point of view was on it. She had never been on a set or anything around it. She's come to understand it.
她以前以为，她说，我不明白为什么演员能得奖什么的。她简直以为导演就像操纵木偶一样控制演员，告诉他们该坐在哪里以及说话的语调。所以这简直就是她对这件事的看法。她从来没有去过片场或接触过相关的事情。她已经开始理解了。
Where'd she grow up, Chechnya? What's going on? Yeah. London, but yeah. Okay. Closer than here. Oh, I do like Lundin. You guys spend a lot of time over there as a result?
她在哪里长大的，车臣？怎么回事？对。伦敦，但对。好吧。比这里近。哦，我确实喜欢伦敦。你们因此在那边花了很多时间吗？
We do, yeah. I love it out there. We always consider moving up there. I noticed the throw pillow behind. Yeah, that's what that is. Yeah, that's what we do here. Look at Sean's right eye. Oh my God, is it open? No, no, the whole show, it's just been half open. The left one's right eye. Oh my God. Is it open?
我们确实花了很多时间，对。我很喜欢那儿。我们总是考虑搬到那里去。我注意到后面的靠枕了。对，就是那个。对，我们这里就是这样的。看肖恩的右眼。哦天哪，它是睁着的吗？不，不，整个节目期间，它都只是半睁着的。左边的那只……右眼。哦天哪。它是睁着的吗？
No, no. The whole show, it's just been half open. The left one's fully open. The right one is really tired. This morning Sean spent 45 minutes bent at the waist outside his front door this morning. It's so true. I was at the ER at Cedars and there's like, it was a seven hour wait. What? What is wrong with you?
不，不。整个节目期间，它都只是半睁着的。左边的那只完全睁着。右边的那只真的很累。今天早上肖恩在他家门外弯着腰持续了45分钟。千真万确。我在锡德尔斯的急诊室，那里简直，等了七个小时。什么？你到底怎么了？
Why didn't you cancel? Because I had, there's no other option. Was Scotty with you? Yeah. So you didn't take the driverless cab this time? I told him, I'm like, fuck off, I'll just take the thing. What's it called again? That's sweet. Waymo.
你为什么不取消？因为我有，没有别的选择。斯科蒂跟你在一起吗？对。所以这次你没坐无人驾驶出租车？我告诉他，我说，滚开，我直接坐那个东西。叫什么来着？太贴心了。Waymo。
Waymo. Waymo. And you did have a good experience, right? Yeah, I love the Waymo. Do they have that yet in New York, Karen? I've never heard of it. It's the driverless side. Oh, that scares the shit out of me. No, I haven't seen any here.
Waymo。Waymo。而且你确实有段不错的体验，对吧？对，我很喜欢Waymo。凯伦，他们纽约现在有这个吗？我从来没听说过。那是无人驾驶的。哦，那可把我吓死了。不，我在这里没见过。
How do you get around New York? Are you a bike rider? Oh, God no, I don't do that either. See, that would fall under hobby probably, or at least exercise, and I don't do that. Yeah, no. Are you a subway guy? Subway, yeah, yeah. That's the best way to get my kids to school. And I don't do that. Yeah, no. Are you a subway guy?
你在纽约是怎么出行的？你是个骑自行车的人吗？哦，天哪，不，我也不干那个。你看，那可能属于业余爱好，或者至少是锻炼，而我不干那个。对，不。你是坐地铁的人吗？地铁，对，对。那是送我孩子们上学最好的方式。而我不干那个。对，不。你是坐地铁的人吗？
Subway, yeah, yeah. That's the best way to get my kids to school. And if it's raining, you'd take a cab. Yeah. No, not today. It's rainy today. Is it rainy today? You know what I've never figured out about the subway
地铁，对，对。那是送我孩子们上学最好的方式。如果下雨的话，你会坐出租车。对。不，今天不。今天下雨。今天下雨吗？你知道关于地铁我一直搞不懂的是
is once you come up out of the stairs after you've reached your destination, I can't figure out whether I'm looking north, south, east, or west, because I can't find the sun. Because you're used to getting in the back seat and your driver just taking you places? No, sir, can you change your radio station?
一旦你到达目的地后从楼梯走上来，我就分不清我面对的是北、南、东还是西，因为我找不到太阳。因为你习惯了坐在后座，然后司机直接把你带到各个地方？不，先生，你能换一下你的广播电台吗？
This is a whole host. I actually requested nobody talk to me on this ride. I do. You know how you know a lot of the times, JB, is because on the avenues, certainly on the avenues, you know which direction they go, whether they go uptown or downtown, so you can kind of get a sense of the times JB is because on the avenues certainly on the avenues You know which direction they go whether they go uptown or downtown so you can look at the numbers I think if you can count you can sort of figure it out But you that that necessitates walking a block to see if the numbers are going up or down. That's that oh, that's my problem
这是一个全体主持。其实我要求这次行程中谁也别跟我说话。我是认真的。你知道很多时候你是怎么知道的吗，JB，因为在大道上，当然是在大道上，你知道它们是朝哪个方向走的，是往上城还是往下城，所以你大概能有个概念……JB是觉得因为在大道上，当然是在大道上，你知道它们是朝哪个方向走的，是往上城还是往下城，所以你可以看看数字。我想如果你会数数，你大概就能弄明白。但那——那需要走一个街区去看看数字是在变大还是变小。就是那个——哦，那就是我的问题所在。
Yes, yeah, you might walk one block out of the way But like I shouldn't have to walk a block to figure out which way I'm going You know you also have have smarty phones now. Do you want to go to a council meeting in New York? Maybe you can be heard, you know what I mean? Well, yeah, what would you suggest? There's somebody at the exit of every station telling you where to go?
是的，对，你可能会多走一个街区，但就像我不该非得走一个街区才能弄清楚我到底在往哪个方向走。你知道你现在也有智能手机。你想去参加纽约的市政会议吗？也许你的声音能被听到，你知道我的意思吗？好吧，对，你有什么建议？每个车站出口都有个人告诉你该往哪儿走？
In England, they take the time to paint on the road there, look left, you know? Maybe New York can say, you are facing north on the ground. But it doesn't say what direction you're facing. No, but I'm saying- It doesn't say north or south. It says left. Case dismissed. Yeah.
在英国，他们会花时间在路上画出来，看左边，你知道吗？也许纽约可以在地上写着，你正面向北方。但它没说你面朝什么方向。不，但我的意思是——它没说北或南。它写着左。案子驳回。对。
That's so you don't get hit by a car. I'm saying, no, I understand, but I'm saying there are efforts that the infrastructure folks can go to, to help out the people on the road. This is real stuff. Sean, remember last week, you were having dinner with Richard and Jenny's
那是为了不被车撞。我的意思是，不，我明白，但我的意思是基础设施人员可以做出努力，来帮助路面上的人。这是真的。肖恩，还记得上周，你在理查德和珍妮家吃晚饭
and you came outside and I was bent over at the waist. This is true. And I said, and I looked up and I go, yeah, hi, Alan. Do you remember that? Oh God, that was, I was one of the hardest times I ever left in my life. It just reminded me, we hunched over at the waist. You know Richard, Richard Erlich?
然后你出来的时候，我正弯着腰。这是真的。然后我说，我抬起头说，嗨，艾伦。你还记得吗？哦天哪，那是，那是我一生中离开时最艰难的时刻之一。它只是让我想起，我们弯腰驼背的样子。你知道理查德，理查德·埃里希（Richard Erlich）吗？
Yeah, he was the world's best realtor. If you're looking for a house in Los Angeles area, contact Richard Erlich. That's a true story. That is true story. And we walk out to our car as the night's over and we're walking out to his driveway and Will goes acting like he's completely bombed out of his mind.
对，他是世界上最好的房地产经纪人。如果你在洛杉矶地区找房子，联系理查德·埃里希。这是个真事。那确实是真事。然后我们晚会结束往车走去，我们朝他的车道走去，威尔表现得好像他完全神志不清、烂醉如泥。
He goes, hey man, can I ask you something? I go, yeah. He goes, do you know where I can get some heroin? I'm just asking for a friend. I'm asking for heroin. I'm asking for a friend. I don't want anything to do with it. By the way, let's not make light of people
他说，嘿，伙计，我能问你个事吗？我说，行。他说，你知道我在哪儿能弄到点海洛因吗？我只是替一个朋友问的。我在要海洛因。我是在替朋友问。我可不想跟那沾边。顺便说一句，我们不要轻描淡写那些
who are struggling with it. No, of course not. It was just a funny thing. Obviously we're not. We're just having fun because Sean happens to be hooked on morphine. Oh God, I don't mean hooked, addicted to. Karen, this is it.
与它挣扎的人们。不，当然不。这只是个搞笑的事情。显然我们没有。我们只是在开玩笑碰巧肖恩迷上了吗啡。哦天哪，我不是指迷上，是对……上瘾。凯伦，就是这样。
We could just talk to you all day knowing that you have nothing else to do. No, he's got to do this all over again. He's got talk to you all day knowing that you have nothing else to do. No, he's got to do this all over again. He's got to do it all over again, right? Is there anything you want to ask Sean? Is there anything, because you've listened to a few episodes, is there anything you need to know from Sean?
我们可以整天跟你聊天，因为你知道你反正也没别的事可做。不，他还得再把这事从头到尾做一遍。他得整天跟你聊天，因为你知道你反正也没别的事可做。不，他得把这事从头到尾再做一遍。他得重头再做一遍，对吧？有什么你想问肖恩的吗？有什么——因为你听过好几期节目了，有什么你需要向肖恩了解的吗？
Go ahead, he's... Ask him why he hates his colon so much. Yeah, why is he always in the hospital? What is wrong? No, because my, yeah. Well, I'm not, just my heart thing is the big thing, but it's all being taken care of. Well, you know why, Kieran,
说吧，他……问问他为什么这么讨厌自己的结肠。对，为什么他总是在医院？到底怎么了？不，因为我的，对。好吧，我不是，只是我的心脏问题是大头，但这一切都在处理中。好吧，你知道为什么吗，凯伦，
if you went to Sean and Scottie's house, every meal, it's like a 12-year-old's birthday party. This is true. Okay. I know. It's true, it's true. Napkins on laps. I kind of eat the same.
如果你去肖恩和斯科蒂的家，每一顿饭，都像是12岁小孩的生日派对。千真万确。好吧。我知道。千真万确，千真万确。餐巾纸铺在大腿上。我吃东西也差不多。
I'm kind of the same when it comes to the food thing. Are you? Yeah. Yeah. You like the food? I do, and it's the shitty stuff. Like my wife the other day reached in and grabbed some Cheetos that I was eating,
说到吃东西，我其实也差不多。是吗？对。对。你喜欢这种食物？我喜欢，而且都是那些垃圾食品。比如我老婆前几天伸手去抓一把我正在吃的奇多（Cheetos），
was about to, and then she let go and said, what am I doing? Wait, what are you doing? Where did these come from? And I said, they were in the house. She goes, how? Stop putting this in our house. Right, yeah.
正准备抓，然后她松手说，我在干什么？等等，你在干什么？这些是从哪儿来的？我说，它们就在家里。她说，怎么回事？别把这东西弄到我们家里来。对，没错。
How old the man are you? 42. Yeah. And I can't be eating like that. So you go to the, do you guys take turns going to the market and doing the shopping? Yeah, and then you know I do that thing where I shop hungry and then I'm buying the,
你多大岁数了？42岁。对。我可不能那样吃东西。所以你们去——你们俩是轮流去超市采购的吗？对，然后你知道的，我会有那种在饿着肚子的时候去购物，然后我就会买……
I find that they have like that chicken in a biscuit. Do you know those like box of crackers chicken? Yes, two bits. I love those. I'll buy like, I'll buy them by the case. I love just pushing the cart row by row by row. No list at all, I'm just gonna go down each row, however long it takes, and look at everything
我发现他们有那种“饼干配鸡肉”（chicken in a biscuit）。你知道那种盒装饼干吗？是的，两口。我很喜欢那些。我会买，我会成箱地买。我就喜欢推着购物车一排又一排地逛。完全不带购物清单，我就是要一排一排地逛下去，不管花多长时间，看看所有的东西，
and see what I want. But you don't put anything in the cart, right? Because you just eat the salads. Oh no, I'm just going to go down each row, however long it takes, and look at everything and see what I want. But you don't put anything in the cart, right? Oh no, I fill it. JBA, I love hearing you describe sort of normal, you know, everyday necessity for people as a novel idea. You know what I mean? It's like a fun- Hashtag relatable. You know what I like to do?
看看我想要什么。但你什么都不往购物车里放，对吧？因为你只吃沙拉。哦不，我就是要一排一排地逛下去，不管花多长时间，看看所有的东西，看看我想要什么。但你什么都不放进购物车，对吧？哦不，我把它装满。JBA，我超爱听你把对大家来说很正常的、日常必需的东西描述成一种新奇的想法。你知道我的意思吗？这就像是一个有趣的——#引起共鸣。你知道我喜欢做什么吗？
I like to walk into an office and like, I can go to all the places. I like to pretend I have a job. Where's my coffee? Work, work, work. Oh, amazing, work. Oh, amazing. Kieran, what a delight you are. You are a delight.
我喜欢走进一间办公室，然后就像，我可以去所有的地方。我喜欢假装我有一份工作。我的咖啡呢？工作，工作，工作。哦，太棒了，工作。哦，太棒了。凯伦，你太逗了。你太逗了。
You guys are fun. You're a good man. You'd be a good dinner hang. Maybe we'll hit you up for dinner in New York. Yes, please. Come see the show. Yeah, I want to see the show. I really want to see the show.
你们真有意思。你是个好人。你会是个很好的饭友。也许我们在纽约时会约你吃晚饭。好的，请吧。来看演出吧。对，我想看演出。我真的很想看演出。
Let's all hang out and do the thing. You guys never do repeat guests on your show either, right? We have done it on live when we did the tour. We did some repeats and had some friends. I remember that. I watched that doc, he was great. That's when I learned from you, Jason, and I think about it every time.
咱们一起聚聚，把这事办了。你们节目从来不找回头客嘉宾的，对吧？我们在做巡演时搞过现场。我们做过一些回头客，请了一些朋友。我记得。我看过那个纪录片，他太棒了。那就是我从你身上学到的，杰森，我每次都想起来。
I'm about to shake a salad, you said, don't shake it. You remember that? Like, whenever you put the dressing in a salad, you went, don't shake it. And I think of it every time now, and I go, oh wait, I'm not supposed to shake it. And I go, wait, why, what's wrong with you? Let it cascade.
当我准备摇匀沙拉时，你说过，别摇。你还记得吗？就像，无论什么时候你把沙拉酱倒进沙拉里，你就说，别摇。然后我每次现在都会想起来，然后我说，哦等等，我不是不应该摇吗？然后我说，等等，为什么，你有什么毛病？让它层叠而下。
Why? Shake it. Shake it. You gotta shake it to get it even. You gotta, yeah. I'm a pretty vigorous shaker now. I've met you. You are a shaker.
为什么？摇匀它。摇匀它。你得摇匀它才能让它均匀。你得，对。我现在是个非常卖力摇晃沙拉的人。我见过你。你确实很会摇。
Let it cascade. Let it cascade. What a t-shirt. Let that dressing, see, merch, this is what you guys need. More quotes like that. Let it cascade, that's a sweater right there. And the Tracy one. That's right. And the Tracy one, which she wears. guys need, more quotes like that. Let it cascade, that's a sweater right there. And the Tracy one. That's right.
让它层叠而下。让它层叠而下。多么棒的一件T恤。让那沙拉酱，看，周边商品，这正是你们需要的。更多这样的名言。让它层叠而下，那正是一件卫衣。还有特雷西的那件。没错。还有特雷西的那件，她穿着的那件。你们需要的，更多这样的名言。让它层叠而下，那正是一件卫衣。还有特雷西的那件。没错。
And the Tracy one, which she wears. Talk to me like I'm Tracy. I would come and see you. You are a guy who you deserve all the success that you're having now, especially considering how hard you worked and how talented you are. Such a massive fan. Dude, honestly, what a thrill to have you.
还有特雷西的那件，她穿着的那件。像对特雷西那样跟我说话。我会来看你的。你是一个值得拥有你现在所获得的一切成功的人，特别是考虑到你工作多么努力以及你多么有才华。超级粉丝。老兄，说真的，能邀请到你真是太激动了。
Yeah, keep going. This is a dream come true, I mean it, thanks guys. KC, KC. Big, big fan. See you in a few months. Go get him. Bye guys. I mean it. Thanks guys. KC, KC. Big, big fan. See you in a few months. Go get him. Bye guys. Bye Karen.
对，继续加油。这真是梦想成真，我是认真的，谢谢你们。KC，KC。超级，超级粉丝。几个月后见。去吧。拜拜，伙计们。我是认真的。谢谢你们。KC，KC。超级，超级粉丝。几个月后见。去吧。拜拜，伙计们。拜拜，凯伦。
Thanks pal. And he's slamming it. They told me to not slam it, but I'm slamming it. Who says not? No, no, no, don't slam it. They said don't slam it. Because you've got a redundant record. Are you doing your record at home?
谢谢老兄。他在猛关上。他们告诉我不要猛关，但我偏要猛关。谁说不要的？不，不，不，别猛关。他们说别猛关。因为你有一个冗余的录音。你在家里做录音吗？
Redundant record. I am, that's why. I gotta do a thing. Wait, do I do a thing now and then I slam it? Do your thing and then you can slam it. This is a great goodbye. Yeah. I don't know how to do it.
冗余的录音。我是，这就是原因。我得做个操作。等等，我是现在做一个操作然后我再猛关吗？做好你的操作然后你就可以猛关了。这是一个绝佳的告别。对。我不知道该怎么做。
What do I do with the thing? So if you bring your mouse to the bottom, do you see that little sound icon? No. Yes, no. Yes. Click on that. And then I hit stop. You guys have to use this as part of the goodbye. Okay, I press stop and then no, I just press stop.
我该怎么处理这个东西？所以如果你把鼠标移到底部，你看到那个小声音图标了吗？没有。有，没有。有。点击那个。然后我按停止。你们必须把这个作为告别的一部分用上。好吧，我按停止然后——不，我直接按停止。
I don't see anything that says save. At the top left, file and save. Share, save. So embarrassed. Save these. So embarrassed. Oh my God, this is such a great goodbye. It's all in the show.
我没看到任何写着保存的东西。在左上角，文件和保存。分享，保存。太尴尬了。保存这些。太尴尬了。哦天哪，这真是一个绝佳的告别。全都在节目里了。
Use it, I'm done? Do I fucking slam it now? We're done, yeah, that's it. Slam it. Slam it. Love you, bye. Love you, bye. Now there's a nice young fella, Will.
用上它，我结束了吗？我他妈现在要猛关了吗？我们结束了，对，就这样。关上。关上。爱你们，拜拜。爱你们，拜拜。瞧，那是个不错的年轻小伙子，威尔。
There is a nice young fella, you're right. What a great guest. That was a good guess. That was a good guest. I've been excited to have him, and like I said, we had to reschedule, and that was a whole thing, but I was like, oh God, we were so close to getting him, so glad we had him on. I've always wanted to meet him,
那确实是个不错的年轻小伙子，你说得对。多棒的嘉宾。那是个好嘉宾。那是个好嘉宾。我一直很期待请他来，就像我说的，我们不得不重新安排，那是一整套流程，但我当时想，哦天哪，我们差一点就请到他了，很高兴我们请他上了节目。我一直很想见他，
because the interviews I've seen him do, I used to like, God, that's a great guy. I wonder if they just got him on a good day. I hope he's really like that and he really is. What a nice guy. He really is like that. I want to work with him, I want to hang with him. Hey Sean, now as you scan the bias.
因为我看过他做的那些采访，我以前经常想，天哪，真是个好家伙。我不知道他们是不是正好在他状态好的时候请到了他。我希望他真的是那样的人，他确实是。多好的一个人。我想跟他合作，我想和他一起玩。嘿，肖恩，现在当你扫视着偏见……
Yeah, I wanted to talk to him about it. I saw his eyes scanning. Well, I'm about to watch Home Alone again because we watch it every year and he's got a little part in Home Alone. Yeah. I love that. I bet she's still getting residuals on that. Probably.
对，我想跟他谈谈这个。我看到他的眼睛在扫视。好吧，我准备再看一遍《小鬼当家》，因为我们每年都看，他在《小鬼当家》里有个小角色。对。我太喜欢了。我敢打赌他现在还在从那上面拿残余版税。可能吧。
They're not thick ones anymore, but fun to see. Actually, you know what film he was in? He was in the first one and also the second one. Which was what? Father of the Bride! Bride! Thatide! Bride! That was pretty good. That was pretty good.
虽然不再是大头了，但看看还是很有趣。其实，你知道他演过什么电影吗？他演了第一部，还有第二部。是什么？《新岳父大人》！岳父！大人！岳父大人！那挺不错的。那挺不错的。
SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess是由罗布·阿姆格夫（Rob Armgerve）、贝内特·巴比科（Bennett Barbico）和迈克尔·格兰特里（Michael Granteri）100%有机手工制作的。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来留下评论。